[Applause]  finally here at six happy you ready for  this 109th birthday to pauline cook 109.  you're not kidding today friends and  family gathered at poets walk memory  care in henderson she tells us her  secret formula to long life  my secret formula your secret formula  well  kind of live it up and  don't get too serious about stuff  i love this enjoy your life  do i get one  that's right absolutely  so  each okay  so here's something about her okay she  was richard nixon's clerical assistant  richard nixon's really her favorite food  is meat and she lived through two  pandemics guys way to go happy birthday  pauline you deserve it eat your cake